I think we're in a kind of period of
late modernism renewed modernism in
which the modern style which was
mistakenly given up for dead in the 80s
with post-modernism has kind of come
back reinventing itself much more urbane
correcting some of the mistakes of
modernism first time around when it was
so anti urban and with much more either
restraint in some cases and clarity and
almost sometimes minimalism and and or a
kind of more expressionistic strain so
that we see different strains and I do
not think that this is a time that can
be summarized in any single ISM anyway
there are too many different things
going on but probably the one that is
kind of the most unifying or compelling
of the time to the extent that anything
can pull a diverse time together would
be this sort of late modernist moment
that we're in we're really good
architects are reinventing the modernist
vocabulary
where we're at right now it's a it's
hard to ever encapsulate that with a
single building I mean there was a time
you know dozen years ago when Frank
Gehry's guggenheim museum and bilbao
seemed to sort of sum up everything and
it did and it was really the symbolic
beginning of a whole age of architecture
the age of intense engagement with
architecture and with doing buildings
that in some cases were really quite
wonderful and brilliant and and profound
even other cases buildings that were
just sort of excessive right now we've
kind of pulled back from that a lot but
we're not entirely sure where we're
going there's a tremendous interest in
sustainability today and
environmentalism and buildings being
responsible from a green standpoint
which is all to the good there's a
greater sense I think of the building as
part of a larger whole and less as an
individual standalone monument so we're
more concerned with urbanism how
buildings relate to each other on the
street and as part of a community we're
more concerned I think with planning I'd
like to hope and so we're not believing
that you can keep growing and spreading
out forever and ever across the
landscape that that we've got to make
our cities denser and tighter in part to
preserve the land I sense a lot of that
right now much more willingness to begin
to consider alternate forms of housing
as reflections of alternate forms of
living and alternate family structures
and things like that you know for a long
time we've just assumed that everybody
would fit into the same little
pigeon-holed box either a little
suburban house or an apartment in the
city or whatever that was designed for a
very traditional nuclear family in fact
family structures are different now and
they're changing and they're more
options and so why aren't there more
housing options at the same time to
reflect that you hear more people at
least talking about that now and I think
if we were not in this difficult
recession where it's tough to build
anything we
see more real stuff happening right now
but with luck we can use this time to
plan to sort of develop ideas and be
ready to do more interesting stuff when
the time comes hopefully pretty soon